in your opinion what are some of the
best soft skills to have at a large tech
company and why that is a good question
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's poppin guys hey hey all right
today I am very very excited for this
video why it's because we've only got
sponsored so this video is gonna be
sponsored by blue apron as you can see
the delicious food that's laid out all
right so blue apron is a meal kit
service and I'm so excited because
finally I can make healthy food for
myself because you know me I always go
out and eat pokeballs or when I cook it
looks like this oh my god it's pretty
disgusting
but yeah so I'm very excited and I get
to eat all this free food and another
reason why I'm super happy about this is
that you know they make really delicious
and healthy food and since you know I'm
getting jacked this is perfect for me
and an something for you guys the first
50 people to sign up will get $50 off
your first two weeks of blue apron which
is great it makes it pretty much like as
cheap as buying groceries okay
all right can't can't come in yeah and
we have a special guest today
we got the girl at 3:04 yeah her name is
Arielle can you tell me a little bit
about yourself I'm a software engineer I
just graduated college 2017 mm-hmm oh I
do iOS but I did web before that so iOS
is totally new to me but I guess due to
my job
nice nice we actually have another
special guest later on but you'll have
to keep watching to find out who all
right what food do you want to make we
have three different stills we got wild
alaskan fettuccine we
aka pasta we got lemongrass ginger
turkey burgers and finally we have
Korean steak oh my god
oh wow you want steak frite so it's all
laid out you know 1 to 6 I asked you
guys on Twitter to give us you know your
best questions about software
engineering so we're gonna be answering
this while we cook oh those are french
fries done yeah those are french fries
my baby that looks okay oh my god no
need for introduction this is my yuko
also oh yeah so which one do you want
shoes you either can choose the
lemongrass turkey or the fettuccine I'm
gonna do the fettuccine fascinating all
right go ahead yeah oh it's so simple
instructions are so simple well use the
oven for though okay if you're not
cooking I'm cooking I'm thinking it's
part of my video ya know once I get my
new apartment because my new apartment
has a dope-ass kitchen and it's actually
really mm-hmm
yeah if you watch my videos you would
know whatever no one watches your videos
that's not true oh yeah it's like in
Japanese and stuff damn it's probably to
pass all this yeah Kimani oh my gosh
mayonnaise comes in a little thing like
this wow you never need to buy any this
is such a good first continue continue
this is like a new experience it's the
first question by Rosa nor hello Joma
oppa I do curious what makes you move
from software engineer to data scientist
thank you
yeah that's a great question I actually
got as that old man
times so the main reason why I switch is
that I want to do something new because
the first time I switch was during my
internship so I did software engineering
internship at LinkedIn and then I wanted
to try data science and I did that at
Facebook and then after I did at
Facebook I realized that you know maybe
sometimes it's not like I really like
the product more than actually solving
the architecture problems and stuff like
that so that's why I really like data
science because you're a lot closer to
the product because they see you're
analyzing data to try to find product
recommendations so it's closer to PM
roll then what software engineer would
be and I realize that that's one thing I
really care about because I was really
into startups really into making my own
products and data science is closer to
product management than that and now I
just love data science because it's just
fun to discover something cool with data
Jumma do you ever cut me yeah flash
pancakes ladies ingredient yeah sure
porygon remember when I came and maker
made curry with you okay when I eat
curry for you okay mitchell whitfield
ass in your opinion what are some of the
best soft skills to have at a large tech
company and why that is a good question
um I would say probably a relationship
building is a good sauce skill to have
in a tech company or our very large tech
company because there's a lot of people
at a large tech of me and the way that
you're going to work well with other
people is to have like relationships
with those people doesn't necessarily
have to be like personal relationships
but just like having some sort of
rapport with a lot of different kinds of
people are going to help you get your
job done it's also gonna help you biting
your network and everyone's gonna like
know who you are and stuff and sometimes
networking is key especially at larger
tech companies recently where am i all
right
I could do this oh yeah yeah
what do i do then I just use a camera
all right you know what you're doing yep
yeah recently something I've been
thinking about is that when you're an
engineer you can obviously show
competence just by writing really good
code but you can demonstrate so much
value by actually taking charge in a
project and that requires a lot of soft
skills so like basically like leadership
skills right running a meeting starting
meetings be able to talk to all the
cross-functional people to get their
suggestions and then like connecting
those suggestions to other people it
just makes you look so much more
competent and then people will actually
start to think of you as someone who can
like own a project and totally bring it
through and and all of that is like soft
skills all of that's talking to other
people talking other engineers maybe
you'd like delegating work even I found
you got a lot so it's really on my mind
okay make sure I get a lot of screen
time so my channel right is your friend
married no he's single haha Luther yeah
in temporary yeah hmm everything yeah
I'm sorry what have
how do I guns like it's all are you
recording
uh-huh yeah don't do things when you're
not recording please record him all the
time
much oh my god I thought you were gonna
just you want me to eat this mrs.
challenge there's a challenge easy
you don't want the taste no I love it
Abdul Halim I asked what did you learn
on the job and not in school that you
wish you learned in school or knew about
it earlier could be technical could be
no yeah okay so on the job especially
I'm working at a larger company a lot of
your work is gonna involve going through
other people's code and that means some
things are gonna take a variable amount
of time and you just don't know how long
they're gonna take so like scoping a
project at school and at work is so
different at least it was for me like at
school you could play do everything the
last day if you really needed to I mean
maybe not for bigger projects but at
work is things are just not gonna take
any amount of time you think so that's
something I've really had to learn and
when I wasn't in tournament I was like
the first time I got I had to like that
yeah what about you Michael I wish I
proved my writing skills yeah cuz like I
thought I was like when I was going in
school I was like I don't know right
like I'm a computer science major I
don't gonna like write angling like
paragraph structure or whatever but then
I found that like whenever you're
communicating what you wrote and like
what code you wrote or like if you're
communicating to other people a sync
what you're doing then you have to have
really good writing skills to come off
clearly and
like communicate really well like even
just like PRS right we have to write a
really good description of what you just
made so that it makes sense to another
person and I wish I like working on my
writing so together and that is also
like when the soft skills another
question yeah we haven't stops go also
one more thing isn't this an actually
fight of me but recently one of our
co-workers said that at school they
didn't really check his code they just
check to see if you're all right and so
that's the thing like at your job if
people are gonna look at your code it
can't just work it has to be like good
code oh yeah quality I think I won mine
yeah a lot of talk about this too like
coding is not just about how fast your
code runs or if it works because the
hope because coding 90% of the time
means you're working for other people
yeah good code means other people can
read your code yeah and then write wall
they gave me trash like my videos like
my coding skills good which programming
language is a good prerequisite for
computer science students in freshman
year what programming my works yeah
Python it's good for interviews yeah it
wasn't your doing question by ecchi what
benefits if there are any that you see
in getting a software engineering degree
versus a computer science degree hmm
yeah and how highly do you think
companies value self projects versus
actual internship and work experience so
two questions okay I would say a
software engineering versus computer
science I'd make school didn't have a
software engineering degree but I think
it depends maybe on like what the school
program is and if it aligns with your
goal
because I can imagine like some software
engineering programs or just like CS
programs out of their schools so I would
say like if you are at a college then
talk to your advisor and see which one
it's like more Joe like what you want to
do and then the second question self
projects versus actual internship or
work experience I guess it depends on
what the South project is but if unless
unless it's like really cool I would say
that like work experience actual
interest in self project because there's
a lot of stuff that you learn in
internships that aren't just about
coding and it's about like working with
a team or working with other people and
communicating and stuff that are really
valuable I think to learn I think is
much a sense how do you keep being
productive in software engineering more
specifically how you do it with hella
distraction around you basically how do
you not procrastinate just always
progress but I think accountability
systems you're good hmm yeah I
personally do get distracted a lot in
general at work also but I ice I have
just learned to accept it because in a
day I have a certain amount of energy
and even if I have more time like like
eight hours in a day it doesn't mean
that I'm gonna work the whole eight
hours because I just get mentally tired
right so it's okay to procrastinate from
time to time like for example study how
did you not procrastinate studying I had
to remove myself from social situations
sometimes like go to a library like lock
myself in a room you know that's kind of
how I had to do it yeah so have a nice
little drink or something like a treat
me not like I meant coffee I'll do that
see there's like a boba place oh my gosh
I would just like get boba
this is my treat yeah I study and then
it kind of puts sometimes it puts into
that mode especially if it's something
that you always have when you're
studying yeah yeah I always like grass
and coal College so great advice but
just do it I think at least at work
other people also want to get stuff done
usually yet some point it's more like
social pressure at work it was like if
you don't get it done then it affects
someone else's yeah that's true that's
more motivation resident college is like
the only person I'm laying down as
myself person makes everything look good
wait one last question for you guys
which is a simple answer I think do you
as seasoned developer have to refer to
documentation and code snippets when
coding at work or do you already have
all the knowledge needed in your head
I'm a robot sets off program oh yeah
there's so much stuff you can't 100% sir
I Google how to write loops in Python at
the daily basis yeah yeah literally
everything I do I copy code snippets
almost meal of course having a good
coast yeah the good that's the thing
that you learn this using developer you
just know what's good and bad come to my
- day okay cool
so here's the food looks very very
delicious thank you may you go thank you
every Alfred for helping me cook this
meal or should we say thank you for
cooking for me and allow me to help
but yeah I'm pretty sure this is
extremely healthy I mean if we look at
the nutritional facts so you fettuccini
you know you get 710 calories for this
one and then for the other ones thick
please we get 610 calories
yeah lots of protein both of them 41
grams 39 grams oh the little alright
let's try it out guys I'm gonna try to
pause the first no more fried actually
I'm gonna try to pasta it's got fish in
a homicide mmm I always so good well
good job me you call this is yo that's
good
you mean thank you blue apron for making
the recipe that's good that was really
good come on al dente I've never had
fish pasta yeah I don't think I've
actually ever made fish possibly before
either but actually he's so good yeah
wow this is actually really good
oh my god I'm in this one all right if I
could make this myself obese oh my god I
so got this
well we should I try at the Karla course
I got butter extra butter yeah you get
more than just this but mm-hmm
gonna help sure if there's like why
would get in large companies cafeteria
food who wins a good day oh you don't
think so I think this is definitely
better than that well better mmm I feels
like I shopped at Whole Foods without
needing to go to Whole Foods and pay for
it yeah yeah pretty much
mm-hmm and I think I can do this with my
girlfriend come on can you just act fine
I could do this you can access my
non-existant yeah my features robot I
won't go girlfriend
all right so passwords thank you so much
blue apron for sponsoring this video
oh my god we have so much fun making
this oh my god so yeah and once again
don't forget
link on the description to get free what
$50 off for your next purchase all right
peace out guys
and then a rap music starts
[Music]